hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his third meditation Rene Descartes
is going to provide an argument for
God's existence one that has proven to
be a bit difficult for some of his
readers to follow so we're going to run
through that argument for God's
existence and one of the reasons why
it's difficult is because it turns on a
distinction that Descartes makes between
what he calls objective reality and
formal or actual reality which is rather
different than how we use those terms
today so that's one issue the other
thing is that those who are accustomed
to thinking about arguments for God's
existence using the classification that
has become quite popular from the time
of Kant on downward distinguishing
ontological arguments from cosmological
arguments from teleological arguments
and then you know throwing everything
else into a sort of a miscellaneous file
they're not going to be able to find an
easy way to categorize what Descartes is
doing within that that classification
because in a certain respect it kind of
looks like an ontological argument it's
relying upon some sort of idea of God
and using that our
you that there has to be something
corresponding to that on the other hand
it also resembles a cosmological
argument and that we're talking about
cause and effect but it doesn't neatly
fit into the classification of either
and it also relies upon a notion of
degrees of being that we find in yet
other arguments for our God's existence
so all that said let's look at the
argument itself we start by looking at
the idea of God and for for Descartes he
talks at many points about God so let's
just look at one formulation he says I
have a concept or I conceive of a God
who is sovereign eternal infinite
immovable all-knowing all-powerful the
universal creator of all things that are
outside of himself or different than
himself and this is a typical way that
the cart would characterize him and he
has all the perfections so it's not
taken to be just those things that
Descartes has rattled off there but
anything that you think of as a
perfection that is a way of having being
to the highest extent that would be God
so all being all knowing that's a
perfection right having created
everything other than himself that's
that's a way of being greater than
everything else that's a perfection
being eternal as opposed to being time
bound or coming into existence at any
given time that's a perfection so you
could think of it as like the sum total
of all perfections that are genuine
perfections that is what Descartes means
by God that is what is contained in the
idea of God and it's with the idea of
God that we have to start now Descartes
tells us that this idea has the greatest
degree of objective reality as a matter
of fact it surpasses any other idea that
you could possibly come up with they're
almost not compared
durable to each other but that you know
how are you going to frame it it's at
the apex God is at the top of the
pyramid when it comes to objective
reality or at the one end of the scale
and nothingness would be at the other
end total non-being so this idea has the
greatest objective reality which means
that it has the greatest amount of
reality as an idea not necessarily as a
reality yet but as an idea it's greater
than any other idea once you can see
that you can start following Descartes
down the line that he is going to
outline here and he's going to bring in
some other important building blocks for
the argument this is something that he
frames in multiple ways you could say
that you can't have something with with
greater reality than its cause whatever
caused that thing he has to have at
least as much or greater reality in that
and so when he's talking about ideas he
says that ideas derive the reality that
they have quoi or as ideas objective
reality from some cause we don't just
get ideas coming out of nowhere he says
not only can non being or nothingness
not produce anything but also what is
more perfect that is what contains in
itself more of reality cannot be a
consequence and a dependence of
something less perfect and he says that
this is a clear truth that we grasp
through what he calls the natural light
and so if you think about this decide
whether you actually agree with him at
this point and if you do then you can
proceed with the argument so ideas if
we're going to play off of this
distinction between material and not
material objective and formal reality
ideas derive their reality
from some cause in which Descartes says
there is at least as much formal reality
as that idea has objective reality so
now we're getting outside of just the
realm of ideas potentially at least
because he does consider the idea or the
the the notion let's say instead that
ideas could you know derive from other
ideas as is the case for example he says
when we compose ideas we take ideas that
have a certain degree of objective
reality and we combine them together and
we get something else that has equal
reality although there is a cause for
that that has greater formal reality and
that's us we are the cause of the ideas
that we call produced right so those at
least have us as a greater cause
Descartes is gonna use this to get us to
discussion about God and when it comes
to ideas we should think about well
where could we actually get these ideas
from could it be that the idea of God
actually doesn't represent anything he
says could it one doesn't have to say
that maybe this idea of God is
materially false that is we have this
massive idea that has the greatest
degree of objective reality but it's got
no connection to anything outside of
itself because in this case we would
have to get that idea from nothing here
he says that is that it would be from it
would be in me from what I have lack or
or deficit or something like that
like some other ideas that I have that
are that are quite indistinct the Curt
thinks that that cannot really be the
case I can't be the source of the idea
of God he says why not well because I am
not infinite I'm finite I'm limited
I'm imperfect if I
what it is that I am I'm not gonna have
gotten this idea about God from myself
and where else am I going to get it if
it if it's going to be from something
that has at least as much formal reality
as a cause as that idea has as an effect
it's not going to be by putting together
stones or any other thing that doesn't
have a great degree of formal reality
not even the great degree of objective
reality as ideas you would have to be
from an actually existing God so it's
very important that Descartes considers
well could I have created this idea of
myself and he says no I can't be the
source of that idea and here he talks a
little bit about the nature of of
infinity right he actually says that the
idea of infinity is not merely a
negative idea he says I don't have to
imagine that I can that I don't conceive
infinity by a true idea or truth giving
idea the high table a day but only by
the negation of what is finite the same
way that I for example comprehend rest
and shadows by the negation of movement
or light why because to the contrary I
see manifested Lior clearly that there's
more reality in infinite substance than
there is in finite substance again he's
using this this distinction between
different degrees of being as part of
this argument so he says and and
beginning from from what I have in
myself with his notion of an infinity
you know I I can do this and I get to
understand God in a certain sense better
than I do myself and this is even
granting that my capacities are so
limited that I cannot comprehend what
infinity is he says it's of the nature
of infinity
that my finite mind can't comprehend it
so that's taking away a possible
objection at this point so what is he
telling us the idea of God has to be a
true idea not only in that we have that
idea not only in that that idea has the
greatest degree of objective reality
that as reality as an idea but that it
has to be in some way corresponding to
however dimly because we can't fully
grasp infinity a genuinely infinite
being possessing all perfections that
would exist in reality not merely
potentially not merely eminently but
with what Descartes calls formal or
actual reality
ergo God exists so he does also have a
few other considerations that he uses to
shore this up and one of these has to do
with the idea of clear and distinct
ideas or the conception of clear and
distinct ideas Descartes takes this as a
hallmark for the truth of ideas and he
says that the idea of God is very clear
and distinct why is that the case well
because everything he says my mind
conceives clearly and distinctly of the
real and the true and here's the
important provision contains some
perfection is contained in that idea of
God so if each of the we could say parts
although they're not really parts
because God is a simplicity as well but
if we want to talk about them as parts
each of the parts is clear and distinct
that means that the idea itself of God
is also clear and distinct and a proviso
there that it has to contain some
perfection so even though we could have
for example a clear and distinct idea of
something that doesn't contain a
perfection you know perhaps a very very
clear and distinct idea of the letter A
that's not going to be in God right
because it's not a perfection so what do
we have here we have an argument that
begins from the idea of God says that
there's something really unique about
this idea namely that it has the
greatest degree of objective reality
that is it has the greatest reality as
an idea among other ideas within my mind
brings in the notion of cause and effect
the causes of ideas and connects the
formal or actual reality of the thing
its existence in reality as we would
call it to this objective reality the
idea of it as a representation or as an
idea itself within the mind we say that
there has to be at least as much formal
or actual reality in the thing in the
cause as there is objective reality in
the effect we know that it has the
greatest degree of objective reality so
its cause must have the greatest degree
of actual reality it cannot be in me it
must be in God and we can conclude by
talking about what Descartes then thinks
about this idea of God and how it got in
him he suggests that the idea of God
which is actually an innate idea as has
been revealed through through examining
this is sort of like the mark that a
worker or a craftsperson places on their
product and so it allows Descartes
because this idea of God has been placed
within him by God to trace his way back
to his own maker and to understand
himself in relation to that infinite
perfect being which must exists
according to Descartes by using that
very idea of God so that is the argument
as he sets it out for God's existence in
meditation 3 he will provide another
argument which is very clearly an
ontological argument
for God's existence in meditation five
but this is perhaps regarded by some of
the experts a stronger argument at least
on its face as we find it here in
meditation three
you